- Good morning believe nation!
My name is Alex and my one word is belong.
And I believe that the world
would be a better place
if more people felt that they belonged.
To help you on your journey,
today's message is,
don't stop!
Over to you, Tony Robbins.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- There is another level.
The only reason you keep seeing
there isn't is you feel so exhausted about
where you are.
But life, the universe or God
is just testing you
because there is another level.
If this is good,
giant shift to excellence,
giant, start poor to good to excellence.
There's a level where all
your dreams are realized.
There's a level that you've
always dreamed about.
It is real,
it has not gone away.
But it takes that extra burst
when you think there's nothing left,
there's no way.
You've tried everything 10 million times
and you keep going.
It's almost like God is
saying if you keep hitting
this wall enough times,
I will see that you will not stop,
that you are filled with that level
of determination and faith and courage
and then the door opens.
And you get to that next level.
And what most people don't know is
the next level is just
two millimeters above
and it's called outstanding
ladies and gentlemen.
Outstanding!
What's it called?
(audience cheering)
- [Audience] Outstanding
What's it called?
- [Audience] Outstanding!
- Outstanding, magnificent, unstoppable,
extraordinary, not excellent.
It's a different level.
It's a level where you
are not one of the best,
you are the best.
And you know what's amazing,
you only have to be two millimeters
more than everybody else
and you get everything.
You get the joy, the laughter, the fun,
the family, the passion, the economics,
the freedom, the spirit, it's all there.
What Jerry Maguire called the Quan baby,
all of it.
And it's just two millimeters above
and most excellent people give up
because they are exhausted.
And there are some people who go,
"The harder I hit it,
the more I hit it,
sooner or later it's going down.
I'm not stopping."
And when you do that enough,
it pops open.
- This message resonated for me a lot
on two levels.
I actually want to share
a quick story with you.
Navy Seals have some
of the hardest training
that they have to go through
both mental and physical to graduate.
And one of the most difficult
things that they have
to go through is called Hell week.
In this one week,
they sleep probably anywhere
from four to 10 hours in a seven day span.
Both their mind, their
body and their spirit
gets pushed to the limits.
Now here's the thing,
they'd been training for this hell week
surviving things like drown proofing
where their arms and legs get tied.
They get tossed in a pool
and they essentially have to get used
to being drowned.
These are top specimens
that you can think of
both physically and
mentally men and women.
And in this last week they just
need to graduate and
survive one more week.
And so here's the thing
that's mind blowing.
Every morning whether it's
three am or four am,
when their instructor wakes them up,
they line up on the beach.
And next to them,
there's a brass bell.
If they want to quit all they have to do
is ring the bell.
They ring the bell,
they quit, that's it, it's done.
They pack up the stuff and leave.
Do you want to know what's
the mind blowing thing?
Most people quit not when they get their
hands tied and thrown in the pool.
When they have to jump
into ice cold water.
When they have to hold
a log over their head
for four or five hours.
Most people quit
in the morning.
Most people quit at the
idea of doing those tasks.
Only a handful of people
actually quit while they're
struggling through it,
while they're trying to hold their breath
and get used to being drowned.
So what does it tell you
about the human capacity?
A lot of the people that ring the bell
are quitting because of
the idea of what's coming.
While most people when they actually,
when they get into it,
they make it through.
And isn't that the truth?
Isn't the thing that psyches us out,
the thing that we hold ourselves
back on is the idea of
going back to the gym?
Is the idea of doing that last set
if you're working out.
Is the idea that you want to read
that extra book to get better at something
that you're trying to learn
about, leadership or whatever.
So here's the thing
that you can learn from Navy Seals
while being in the moment
as something difficult
is coming your way
and you don't want to stop.
Remember that it's a state of mind
that often people quit in,
not when they're in the situation.
So anytime you start doubting yourself,
anytime you want to stop,
anytime you want to quit on something
that's important to you,
realize that my fear,
the reason I want to stop,
the reason I want to quit is
simply because I'm imagining
how difficult it's going to be.
But once you put yourself
in that situation just like
those Navy Seals,
you'll make it through.
And the second thing
that's really important,
is to raise your standards.
It's important, just like
Tony talks about it,
for greatness to happen,
don't be okay when things are just fine.
Or okay, or they're alright.
Push through the wall,
'Cause ultimately,
that's where greatness waits for you.
So the question of the day is,
where in your life right now
you're seeing some success
that you don't want to stop in
and what can you do about it right now?
Leave your comments
below, I'm really excited
to see what you have to say.
I also want to give a big shout out
to Scott J. Weaver Sr.
Scott thanks so much for
purchasing your One Word,
it really means a lot to us
and I hope you are enjoying the book.
Thank you so much for watching.
We believe in you
and we hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
And we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Ent spresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me going
- I've learned,
if you're a farmer.
A farmer understands
better than any
other worker in this country.
A farmer has an understanding
that most people
never achieve in their life.
I really respect
the farmers and their commitment.
But I respect also their understanding.
My Grandfather,
my Uncle
the thing was
to wake up early in the morning,
before you start your day,
you start your day
by feeding all the animals.
I never understood that.
Why am I feeding, slopping these hogs,
bailing this hay for these cows.
taking the food out to the hunting dogs,
going to getting these mules and horses,
walking 'em down to water?
Why am I feeding these chickens man?
All this before I eat?
My Grandfather set me down,
he said, "Young man,
if we don't take care of these animals,
that we are requiring
to take care of us,"
he said, "What's going to happen to us?"
He said, "We depended on them chickens
to lay eggs,
to give us meat.
We depended on
them hogs for meat .
We depended on them mules
to pull the plow so we could plant.
We depended on them horses
to drag all these wagons around.
We depended on these hunting dogs
to go out in the woods and uncover
the animals for us."
He said, "And what
I respect about farmers is,
they understand that everything
comes in seasons.
There is a planting season
and you got to plant and plant and plant
and plant, plow, till, hoe the rows.
You got to do all that.
Seed it, fertilize it
in order for a crop to grow.
Now here's what happens some years,
some years there's a drought.
Ain't no rain, ain't no crops.
Some times it's a flood.
Wipe out all the crops,
all the plants, but guess what,
you still got to do the plant.
Because what you're banking on
is just enough rain,
just enough sunshine
so you can harvest.
And even if they crops get washed out,
even if the floods come,
even of the drought come,
the thing about the farmer,
they do it all again.
Because they understand
that eventually you'll
be able to harvest."
And that's what I respect about farmers
and that's my life.
- I wanted to talk to you about like
is it, the transition that
very successful people make
and either they make it or they don't.
And the transition is
to go from being hungry
and filled with all this angst
to being like stupid, wealthy and famous
but still keeping your art relevant.
How do you do that?
- Ah huh, we're still
super competitive people.
We're really perfectionists and we hate
to let each other down.
There's always a better riff coming.
There's always a better album.
Maybe there's the never satisfied part
to us that will keep us going till we die.
There's always the ultimate lyric
that's going to connect
to everyone in the world or something.
There is always a better something
that we haven't got yet.
- Like the man said you pick up the pace.
If you don't pick up the pace,
you'll be left behind.
I'm amazed at the people
that lack the flexibility
to pick up the pace.
They just get in a rut.
I stroll down here,
and I'm going to stroll back.
I'm going to stroll over here,
I'm going to stroll over there.
One of the most
amazing things about
the disaster at Malaysia
is when it happened,
everybody had to pick up the pace.
All the news media had
to pick up the pace.
They were booking night flights
and they were flying over here
and flying over there.
Somebody had to work overtime.
Won't be home for three days.
Typing in the middle of the night,
research going on
because when something happens,
everybody got to pick up the pace.
That's why I can't deal with people
who cannot pick up the pace.
Don't be strolling
when I got to a 911 on you.
I need people who can
pick up the pace.
(congregation cheering)
It's like the neighbor
said, "Pick up the pace!"
Something is about to happen,
pick up the pace.
Something's about to happen,
Something is about to happen,
pick up the pace.
I came to tell the young people.
Pick up the pace, pick up
the pace, pick up the pace.
Something is about to happen!
The danger of low expectations.
(congregation cheering)
I would rather aim
for the satrs,
and not hit them
than to not aim at all.
I would rather go after it and not get it
than not go after it at all.
I'd rather try and fail
than not try at all.
I don't want to live with the idea,
I wonder what would have happened
had I done more with my life.
I'm going to go for it
come Hell of high water.
I'm going after my destiny.
Touch your neighbor and say run!
- [Congregation] Run!
You got to run after your destiny.
You can't stroll after your destiny.
You can't walk after your destiny.
You got to run!
Somebody holler run!
- [Congregation] Run!
- You got to run.
You got to run.
You can't just wake up
in the morning and let me see
what's going to happen today.
I don't know what I'm going to do.
I don't know what I'm going to wear.
I don't know what I'm going to cook.
I don't know where I'm going to go.
I just woke up.
Ah, you should just stay in the bed.
Give the day to somebody
whose going to run after their destiny.
Give the day to somebody who has a plan,
who has a strategy
because success is never an accident
and if you don't want it,
get out of my way.
Because there are some people
who want to do something with their life,
who will run.